(piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked,
large-brained,
long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism,
we grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(musical tones)
(upbeat music)
- So the idea that women have evolved
to be plant gatherers and men hunters
has dominated evolutionary thinking
in the popular imagination for decades.
It's been suggested that
men are better navigators
than women as a result of a long history
of natural selection on hunters
who can pursue mobile prey
across vast landscapes
without getting lost.
Men are thought to be more
cooperative than women
because throughout our
evolutionary history
they've needed to work together
to bring down hunted prey
much larger than themselves.
Men's hunting is argued to
have driven the evolution
of our two-legged gait,
supplied the nutritional advantages
and protein and fat to support
our energetically-expensive brain
and given our juveniles the luxury
of a long pre-reproductive
life of relative leisure
in which they can take the time to learn
all the skills of adulthood.
Although it's widely recognized
that women's gathering
is usually the more reliable contributor
to family subsistence,
we also tend to think
that men's hunting must be
on the whole more productive
than women's foraging
because they often take
very large animals.
Some have even argued that the
origins of the nuclear family
where men and women
cooperate in different tasks
lie in the evolutionary origins
of female specializing in childcare
and depending on a
man's hunting production
in order to feed her children.
The generalization that men
tend to hunt and women gather
holds for some well-known
contemporary hunter-gatherers.
So among the Hadza in
Tanzania for example,
women primarily gather plant foods,
lower-quality small-packaged food items
high in carbohydrates.
And men typically spend their time hunting
acquiring higher-quality large-packaged
food items high in protein and fat.
Similarly among the Juǀʼhoansi
in Botswana and Namibia
and the Ache in Paraguay,
women specialize almost entirely
on plant-based foods while men hunt.
However this is not a universal pattern.
There is a great deal of variation
among hunter-gatherers
in the extent to which
women do specialize on plant foods.
And many hunter-gatherer
women do acquire animals.
There's the Ata, the Ainu, and the Dene
where women hunt deer.
The Cree where women
hunt caribou and geese.
Central African Aka women
hunt for duikers and forest pigs.
Mixed-gender communal hunts for rabbits
were common among the Shoshone,
and Paiute women hunted and in many cases
still hunt ground
squirrels and prairie dogs.
Australia is another place
that challenges our understanding
of who hunts and why.
Across Australia pre-historically women
were active hunters.
They had a primary focus
on the hand capture
of small to medium-sized animals.
And in many locations,
women skillfully used
fire and hunted with dogs
to improve their efficiency.
For example, Phyllis Kayberry
found Walmajarri women
in the Kimberly in 1935
were using dogs to hunt
kangaroo and monitor lizards.
And she suggested that
the family was dependent
on the woman's efforts to a greater extent
than on those of her husband.
In the 1950s, Jane Goodall also found
that Tiwi women were active
and productive hunters.
And she too characterized women
as the most consistent providers
not only of plant foods,
but of meat as well,
especially meat from small animals.
People I work with, Martu.
Martu women of Australia's Western Desert
too are hunters more than anything else.
On any given day between about 60 to 70%
of the bush food that's produced
is from women's hunting.
Women take more than half of the perentie.
This is one of the largest
species of monitor lizard,
aside from the Komodo dragon.
Women also take a little more
than half of the feral cats.
Feral cats spread into the desert
starting about 100 years ago
and were readily adopted
as prey by Martu hunters.
Women will take about 20% of the bustards
and 6% of the kangaroos.
So bustards are the largest
flying bird in Australia
and males can weigh up to 20 kilograms.
Kangaroo are the largest
endemic non-human in Australia
and weigh up to 80 kilograms.
So these are large for Australia,
not for Africa, but for Australia.
The staple prey of Martu women
are the smaller sand monitor lizards,
sometimes called goanna.
And they acquire more than 80% of them.
They're easily the most abundant
large vertebrate in the desert.
They weigh about half a kilo.
Women hunt them in two
ways which vary seasonally.
In the hot summer months
they track the monitors
on the surface hoping to chase them
to trees or corner them in the open
to avoid having to dig
them out of their dens.
In the winter the monitors
are denned most of the time
and they have to be dug out.
So to accomplish this and also to aid
in the search for fresh dens,
women burn the spinifex grass
that obscures the tracks and signs.
Women often cooperate with each other
in sand monitor and perentie hunting.
So they work together to
burn an area for hunting
to locate tracks and dens
and then to extract the animal.
Now the most important thing nutritionally
about a monitor lizard is not the meat,
it's the fat.
So lizards become dormant
in the cool season.
They lay down about 10 to
20% of their body weight
in the form of large fat
bodies in the abdomen and tail.
And most people say a skinny lizard
isn't actually worth eating.
So women really pride themselves
on being able to find
and capture fat ones.
Now while Martu women do a lot of hunting,
they also do most of the collecting too.
So they produce nearly
100% of things like roots,
98% of insect larva, 90% of the fruit,
a lot of the nectar and
about 30% of the honey.
Now in comparison,
men are looking for small things.
About 30% of the time
they're out foraging,
but most of the time they prefer to search
for the larger animals like
emu, kangaroo and bustard.
And rather than hunting
cooperatively like women,
they primarily hunt alone.
Now the social context of hunting
is similar to what you might see
in any hunter-gatherer society.
So women leave the residential camp
in a group of other women,
often with children along.
They establish what
they call a dinner camp.
They acquire food.
They return to that
temporary dinner camp to cook
and consume food socially,
and then they return
to the residential camp
at the end of the day.
So the question that I'm
gonna to start off with
is why are women hunting?
So traditionally, if we
think about men's hunting,
the goals of men's hunting
are explained usually in one of two ways.
So either men are hunting in order
to provision a nuclear family
or men are hunting to show off their skill
and attract alliances and
favorable attention from women.
In many cases, the kinds
of hunting that men do
don't appear to be well-designed
to provision others.
And when men focus almost
solely on large animals,
they sometimes run the risk
of coming home empty-handed
especially in more arid
environments such as this one
where animals are patchy and
very infrequently encountered.
So per hour spent hunting,
a kangaroo hunter does tend
to average a higher return
than a monitor lizard hunter
taking home over a kilo of meat,
while a sand monitor hunter
gets only 1/3 of that.
But the meat from larger animals,
kangaroo, bustard, and that sort of thing
comes in only very infrequently
about once and in every five hunts.
And although the average is higher,
there are often many days when nothing
is acquired by any hunter.
So in comparison, women's hunting
is much more reliable than men's.
They don't have as many big bonanzas,
but they also don't have as many days
with less than they might need.
Men only end up out-producing
women on 25% of days.
And on 37% of days no men are successful
at hunting any type of game.
Fully 1/3 of these meat droughts
are between about three
and six days in duration.
And for women in comparison,
failure is less than 5%
and they don't have any meat droughts.
So even though larger animals
have a higher mean return,
in reality, this obscures the fact
that men's production comes in the form
of these periodic huge bonanzas
and long meat droughts
rather than a steady daily stream.
The meat from larger animals
is also distributed widely.
The hunter keeps only
about 10% for himself
and his own family.
After sharing, the returns
to a hunter's family
in terms of the grams of meat
per hour hunting is the same,
regardless of what kind of
animal has been acquired.
Now if women's hunting is more reliable
and provides similar payoffs
to family consumption when successful
as does men's hunting,
then it might suggest maybe
that the goals of foraging for
men and women are different
that men might be hunting
to show off their skill
and attract alliances
and favorable attention,
while women are foraging simply
to feed themselves and their families.
So women hunt more
reliable smaller animals
and they trade off this
reliability with larger harvests
because reliability is a better way
to reduce the risks of going hungry.
So it might suggest something
like men hunt to share
and women hunt to eat.
Men use the hunting and
sharing of highly-valued meat
to engage themselves in
these political arenas
of social competition and social support.
And kangaroo hunting by men
is an overtly political game
where young men hunt
for public consumption.
They donate their labor to gain the trust
that's required to gain access
to deeper levels of ritual secrets
which are very important for men.
They work to provide meat for all,
especially in-laws and potential in-laws
without any material reward
in order to gain the trust of older men
who guard the way that
secret ritual knowledge
is transferred and gained.
So a man who demonstrates willingness
to work for the public good
is trusted with more ritual secrets
and he can rise in the ritual hierarchy.
A man who demonstrates willingness
to work for his in-laws
was traditionally trusted
with the opportunity
to marry their daughter.
Hunting for men is as
much about assuring trust
and cooperation in the
distribution of meat,
as it is about showing off
skill and acquiring meat.
When men talk about the
benefits of hunting,
they emphasize that they hunt to share,
they don't hunt eat or
favor their own children
and families over others.
If men hunt to share,
do women then hunt only
to feed their families?
When you hunt with Martu women
what puzzles you the
most is not the hunting,
it's actually the sharing.
So more than 70% of the time
women's harvests of small animals
are shared well beyond their own families.
And on an astounding 23% of lizard hunts
a successful hunter will
take nothing for herself.
she gives it all away either
to her own family members
or other people sitting
around the cooking fire.
When women share, they often
exchange identical lizards
and the hunter will always give away
the largest prey to someone else.
Lizards are shared to others
who have already eaten.
In this video, the hunter returned late
and she's the last to
cook and share her harvest
and she gives away
nearly the entire harvest
to other women and men in the group.
She keeps only the bottom
half of one for herself.
One of the women that
cooperated with her hunting,
she receives three lizards
in the initial divisions.
She passes two to those sitting behind her
and one to the woman on her left.
And the hunter passes one to her husband.
Things are transferring back and forth.
And ultimately, out of a
harvest of six large lizards,
each hunter received less than 8%.
And all of the non-hunters got portions
that were actually bigger than each
of the hunter's portion.
And the goal in this distribution
was to make sure everyone present
around the fire had an equal-sized portion
and nobody went hungry.
Not only do women share
extensively with each other,
they share in ways that don't
make sense economically.
So women often exhibit a
producer's disadvantage in sharing.
So when you have a
producer's disadvantage,
the size of the portion the hunter,
the producer keeps,
is smaller than the
average size of portions
given away to those that
didn't participate in the hunt.
And the usual cross-cultural pattern
is for producers to take an advantage
to compensate themselves
for paying the cost of
going out and acquiring
the food item, right?
They usually keep a portion that's bigger
than any of the portions that
are given out to non-hunters.
But when Martu women hunt small animals
like monitor lizards,
they often keep a smaller
individual portion
than the average portion size
given to a non-hunter or family member.
And we don't see this pattern for men.
When men share small animals,
they'll take the producer's advantage
and they'll keep a larger
portion for themselves.
Women compared to men also
give away more portions.
Given an average-sized harvest,
women will give out more than twice
as many portions as men.
They usually give out around six
compared to men who give out two.
Because they give out
more portions than men
their average portion size
is a little bit smaller,
but they prevent the portion size
of becoming too small
by stinting themselves
in favor of feeding others.
Now the cost that the hunter pays
doesn't seem to be balanced
by shares coming in.
So a successful hunter gets
significantly less from others
than an unsuccessful hunter
or someone who didn't hunt at all.
So that the hunter who acquired the most
often takes home the
smallest share of meat
after all sharing has been accounted for.
So women are way too
generous with small prey
than we might expect
if we're thinking about
sort of the simple economics of sharing.
It's also the case that in the sharing
women are not just sending
those larger shares to family members,
stinting their own consumption in favor
of their children or their close kin.
Women also share widely beyond
their own kinship network
and they also share mainly to other women.
So this is a network of
sharing relationships
between people who made
dinner camps with each other.
The circular nodes, the circles are women.
The squares are men.
And the color corresponds
to the kinship clusters
in the bottom diagram.
Those are the four, five
major kinship clusters
in the community.
The ties between each of the nodes
are those who had shares of
meat passing between them.
Sharing cross cuts kinship ties
and it brings together women
from all kinship clusters
in the community.
So our hypothesis that women are hunting
to provision their families
seems poorly supported.
Why hunted at all if
it's only going to share,
if you're only going to share most of it
to unrelated dinner camp members.
Martu themselves suggest
that one of the main reasons
that women hunt is to acquire meat
to share with other women.
When Martu women talk about hunting
they describe their underlying motivation
as hunting to share.
This is especially the case for women
who are known as murtilya, good hunters.
Anyone can gain the
status of a good hunter,
but to be a murtilya, you
don't simply produce more,
you also share more of that
production with others.
So as one hunter put it, "When
a murtilya goes out hunting,
"she has a good feeling that
she's going to get so much
"and be able to feed others.
"Good hunters always think
that when they go out
"and it helps them to hunt better.
"When a really good hunter goes out,
"she gives so much away
"and takes home only a
small piece for herself,
"but she will always walk
away feeling pukurrpa."
Pukurrpa is what women see
is the reward for murtilyas.
So pukurrpa means generally
warmth and happiness.
But it's a happiness that's the product
of generosity that binds people together.
Without generosity, you
feel you're not in a family,
you're just for yourself
not for everybody,
you don't share things.
According to Martu, good hunters share
in order to demonstrate their commitment
to building family and
contributing to the public good.
and this is the kind of sharing
that we would experience
around the dinner table.
It's the sharing that
cements social relationships
that feeds and nourishes,
but treats everyone like family.
Theoretically, we know that the generation
of warmth and trust or
demonstrating generosity
tends to have substantial effects
on the likelihood of cooperation.
And there's been quite a
bit of experimental work
suggesting that people
tend to cooperate with
and trust more of those
who demonstrate generosity.
And this suggests that one
reason women share so widely
may have something to do with
their cooperative social networks.
Martu women are more than twice as likely
as men to hunt cooperatively.
And for some hunting activities
more than 40 times
likely to be cooperative.
Women also cooperate in childcare, cooking
and other daily activities in ways
that cross cut their
residential group memberships.
Older and younger women,
even those from different hearth groups,
will team up to cooperate in childcare
and different forms of foraging
and subsistence activities,
dividing their labor
so that some will hunt
while others collect.
One of the most frequent
forms of cooperation today
is in small animal hunting.
So this is a small animal
cooperative hunting network.
Hunting partners help each other out
in tracking, digging
and searching for prey.
They usually pool their catch.
Again the same sort of colors
are indicating the kin groups.
And it turns out that women who are
more generous on average,
but not those who are the
necessarily the best hunters
are more central in this
cooperation network,
meaning they have more partners
and they have more partners
who are also more generous.
So this supports the hypothesis
that one of the main
reasons that women share
is to foster more
cooperative relationships
with other women.
So this story of women's
hunting in desert Australia
gives us a much different picture
of the goals of hunting and
its associations with gender
than we've generally gotten
from another hunter-gatherers.
It breaks a lot of our assumptions
about who hunts and why.
Foraging women can be
efficient hunters and trackers,
and small animal hunting can be
just as productive and more reliable
than large animal hunting.
Women can even specialize on small animals
if it's reliable enough.
Women can support a number of others
from their hunting
efforts, not just children,
and can engage with others as cooperative,
political and social agents
outside of the spousal union.
Women could share meat outside
of their immediate families
and draw on those ties
created through meat sharing
to engage in other cooperative endeavors.
Women can form divisions
of labor with other women
and in so doing, collaboratively (groans),
collaboratively both care
and provision dependence with meat
independently of men.
So a model of the origins of
human hunting and sociality
based on women's acquisition
and sharing of small animals
I think is at least as plausible
if not more so than models based on
men's hunting of big game
and women's dependence on
men's hunting production.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)